you make that conscious decision of you
know what starting from today
i'm going to be black or i'm going to be
the poor funniest things that she ever
said which i didn't know was a thing she
said i'm trans racial
no this lady said the same [ __ ] [ __ ]
the [ __ ] is with the
this this lady said the same [ __ ] she
identified as trans black
dude you can't make up [ __ ] horror
experience
it goes i was born in this filthy white
skin
my whole life but i knew
i was gonna be kissed by the golden
black sun yeah
but um the yeah i think the most
hilarious [ __ ] about this is that she
cancels [ __ ] i'm trans racial too then
ho
the [ __ ] that's the crazy thing in five
four three two one hello everybody
welcome to another episode
of the genius brain podcast what's up
y'all
we have edric back in the house today
sir talking about some funny [ __ ]
yeah yo i read this comment the other
day that was so [ __ ] funny
this dude wrote he goes your podcast
title is the most pretentious thing i've
ever heard in my life
like you don't talk about anything
intelligent yeah you guys just make
stupid jokes
like bro genius brain is sarcastic it
means you're dumb you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're so stupid oh bad that's like it's
like if you just took a moment because
if you don't know
what the origin of that word or phrase
or whatever is
just take a moment yeah it's not it
doesn't take too long to google
i know also too genius brain isn't even
an actual word yeah
yeah it's it's already a two words that
i compounded together
right so what the [ __ ] are you talking
about guy and i'm i wonder what these
people when they write this stuff and
they're writing something they think
it's so [ __ ] profound yeah yeah that
they want people to be
oh man i [ __ ] agree with you man this
is just a bunch of dumbasses talking
about stupid [ __ ]
that's exactly what genius brain is
sarcastic you [ __ ] face
you [ __ ] virgin i mean but a lot of
these people who are commenting online
man
you gotta you gotta well i mean those
people who are making those type of
comments anyway
you gotta assume that they're probably
lonely and angry
don't got much friends if any friends
probably when they die nobody's going to
care
don't leave that piece of [ __ ] only
their mom shows up at the funeral
well actually no at that point unless
you die in early death but that's good
there's people in this world man that
you all
you think that everybody has friends
there's some people in this world i'm
finding out that they actually don't
have friends yeah and i'm not making
fun of them or anything i'm just i don't
know what is it like to be in that
situation where you have nobody to turn
to
it's so odd well it's sad first of all
because some of those people might not
beat dicks and [ __ ]
who who just constantly drive people out
of their life right and that's the
reason why they have no friends
maybe some of them are genuinely nice
and good people but they're just
socially awkward or anti-social or
suffer from anxiety so they can't really
engage with people
i mean who knows right those are the
people that i want to really meet
because i want to understand how how did
you end up that way
you want to do a case study i do i want
to do a [ __ ] case
how did you end up to the point where
every person that you met they ran the
[ __ ] away from you
or you couldn't you know navigate
yourself
through a conversation ever in your life
yeah i find that so odd because i know
because when you're weird or maybe
sometimes when you're an outsider or an
outcast
outsiders and outcasts can find other
outsiders
and outcasts and they'll find something
in common and maybe they'll hate the
world together they'll at least have
one best friend yeah but there have been
people
that i met personally at certain shows
they'll come up and they go listen i
don't have any friends i only just came
here just to see you and
you're the you i feel like you're my
friend because you know you you say
things that i agree with but i don't i
don't know anybody out here and it's
just me
i'm looking at them like yo what the
[ __ ] how did this happen like how did
you
how did you not have a single friend
yeah um
i i don't know man it's hard to say i i
feel like a lot of the times
uh it's just i don't know man they could
they could
have gone through those their formative
years just kind of getting picked on
and and as a result it just made them
shun people or even
scared to engage with people because
it's always like something's wrong with
me
people don't like me people always make
fun of me i'm a [ __ ] loser i'm worth
so it's like kind of uh it's like a
self-fulfilling prophecy
yeah almost a self-fulfilling prophecy
and their self-worth
is just such at a such low that they
don't maybe feel like they
deserve companionship or a significant
other
or you know just just kind of along
those lines and then they just end up
being stuck
have you seen um do you know jason
jason lee he's he does this channel
called the jubilee project
and they do a lot of like socially
conscious i'm i'm like kind of
jubilee project rings a bell from like
back in the day so they'll have certain
videos where they'll have like a [ __ ]
taught to a blood
and all this other stuff which is funny
because when i first started this
podcast i wanted to have like those type
of conversations
yeah but i got a little scared i don't
want to you know so
they just killed me in here but they
they did one where it was feminist
versus um what's
what's the what's the opposite of a male
feminist or a female feminist a
female feminist what's the opposite of a
feminist a female feminist
genius brain baby i don't know what is
the word for that what is that
there's feminists and for the males is
what it's a melanist i don't
know i don't know i don't know what the
word for that but either way they
basically had
um pro-men rights versus pro-female
rights right which i didn't realize that
there was men fighting for men's rights
i didn't know that was a [ __ ] thing
yeah which i thought it was hilarious
yeah because i don't think anybody has
ever said
or looked at the male genders that we
don't have
stuff that the female gender has right
you know what i'm saying so i thought it
was hilarious and when i first looked at
that video i thought
i assumed that it was a funny video like
a parody but these guys are actually
people who are fighting for
quote-unquote men's rights
i mean what i don't understand what they
would be fighting for i don't know you
should watch that video it's very
interesting
it's like fairly recent it's i don't
know if it's maybe a couple years ago a
year ago okay but there was one kid on
there he is
hilarious because he is the definition
of what you would think a [ __ ] male's
right male rights activist is
and it's this kid who like lives in his
mom's basement this
chubby little white boy and as he's
speaking to these women across that are
sitting across from him
he's not even making eye contact with
him he's looking at the floor
and he's talking about what a male's
role in society is and how women should
be
yeah and it's like dog you you have
never seen a woman naked never touched a
woman never kissed a woman but you want
to tell a woman where her place is in
society and at home
it's like dog it just sounds like these
incels you know
he is definitively a [ __ ] insult
it's crazy they hate women because they
can't get women for whatever reason
and then they start to develop all these
crazy ideas
of what a woman is how women should act
um and most of the time is very
misguided
you say [ __ ] like women belong in the
kitchen type of [ __ ]
he goes i prefer uh traditional uh
female and male gender roles as he's
saying this he's looking at the floor
looking all around he can't even look at
this teenager or like a teenager
okay wow i mean that's even worse
because even if you had that point of
view
your world view has not been shaped
enough at a yeah who the [ __ ] do you
think you are at the age of 16.
what experience do you have in that type
of dynamic between a male and female to
be able to speak that definitively
about a woman's role should be this or a
woman's role is this
right so you're a [ __ ] teenager man
he was saying some funny [ __ ] because he
was also talking about how
you know obviously uh physiologically
men
are stronger than than women right just
you know statistically speaking
obviously there's gonna be certain women
that are stronger than men yeah but he
was
he was kind of making that a point but
the funny thing is is like i bet you
any one of these girls can [ __ ] you up
at any time bro
shut the [ __ ] it was one of the it's
funny it's hilarious it's a little
irritating watching this video yeah it's
probably one of the best videos that
they make you have to watch that [ __ ]
yeah no i mean
i could i could already kind of get an
idea of
what type of people or what type of guys
um would be on that video because
i've definitely seen comments like that
online um especially on places like
reddit
where you know these people are uh brave
because they're anonymous nobody will
ever know
who they are where they are right
there's something to be said about that
though like i i
i definitely think that there's
something sh there's something should be
done
about that it's not like i want to
police or control
um some you know freedom of speech or
anything like that no matter what the
platform is whether it's in person or
whether it's online but because now
people don't have that sense of personal
responsibility
and there aren't any consequences for
that people can mouth off however the
[ __ ] they want
yeah and it's it's a little it it even
annoys me i've been on this space for a
very long time yeah
but like one of the most annoying
comments that i always get is that
for example i told the story about um
it's a story that i've told like three
or four times over and it's that time
when
on podcasts on podcasts on on other
people's podcasts too
and it's almost like i have to bring
people in
to to prove what i'm saying is to verify
this verify this story
but it's literally the story when i was
in college and i pulled a knife on
somebody
and the weird thing is is it's it's it's
a lot of times it's these kids who are
anonymous right yeah but you could go on
their page and they'll click on and see
what they are
they're gamers they don't they literally
have zero interaction with human beings
and they're like 14 or 15 years old yeah
some of them are even older and they go
impossible it's because they look at
somebody like me who i'm a very nice and
i speak well and they go that's
impossible there's no way you were
involved in stuff like that
i'm like i'm not telling you like it's a
treasure like it's something i'm very
happy that you and i just grew up very
differently
and i think like for them because
they've only seen things on tv they
never grew up around certain people
yeah and they can only assume how how
people
are based on how they look they go oh if
somebody did dangerous stuff or they got
into a fight
they need to have tattoos they need to
be in a gang and these are the only
people that will fight
that will get into fights and it's so
odd and it's like
and it's not my point to go ahead and
prove this to anybody else
but it's it's a weird thing how somebody
could sit in a seat and they try to make
themselves
feel a certain way by telling somebody
else that what they live isn't real well
i mean
listen man a lot of these guys and girls
anonymity is their greatest strength
online
you know the fact that they can hide
behind an avatar
or an alias a username whatever the case
is
that emboldens them yeah and so you know
there's no real way to police that i
mean
obviously places like forums uh
subreddits
the the admins can ban them you know but
other than that it's not going to stop
them from going around expressing their
views and their opinions about
certain subject matter the way they want
to um
and it's like i i get it because
remember i told you too sometimes i get
baited
seeing [ __ ] on twitter where it's like i
know
what that entails i know the whole i'm
gonna be going down if i
engage in this but once in a while it
rubs me the wrong way
just just a certain wrong way where i
gotta
say something and then afterwards you're
always like why the [ __ ] did i even take
the time to do that even if it was one
two like a scratch you need to itch yeah
i know but
you play stupid games you win stupid
prizes right for sure and
every time i'm like ah
i i feel like i said my piece but at the
end of the day it accomplished nothing
because this person or you know i mean
i'm not any better too because sometimes
i do things that piss people off and it
makes me laugh super hard
well that's just trolling yeah because
hey yeah so you know
i do i don't do it to somebody anonymous
but i do it to somebody who says
something
dumb and then i'll write something even
more dumb yeah just because i know
what's going to make them angry
you know they'll write something like
they'll write some comment and i know
for a fact what happens is that
when they write their comment i write
one back immediately if i happen to
catch it yeah i didn't give it like 10
seconds
so they could read my comment and then
then i blocked them because i know that
they read the [ __ ] i literally told
them that i'm gonna [ __ ] their mom yeah
and then i just jacked off in her eye
and they that's the last thing that they
read and they try to write back and they
go you've been blocked
i know it kills them for a [ __ ] fact
because i've done that before and
they've created a second instagram
account just just to write back and say
so you're [ __ ] afraid of me so you
don't want to say all this [ __ ] then i
write the same comment
again and then i block them again and
i'm just
dying laughing because i know for a fact
how much it bothered them because they
had to go out of their way to create a
new email
to create a new instagram account just
to write something again nah i mean
that's the thing
i'm not gonna lie man sometimes i troll
two just because
sometimes people take things way too
seriously
and it's like come on man it ain't that
serious you know what i mean it's hard
to be above it man
it's so hard sometimes it is it is that
well that's exactly why i
i [ __ ] took a break from social media
and kind of detach myself from that
because
you know the more you're on the
platforms and the more you're engaging
with it the higher the chance you're
gonna see one of those things
where you're just like oh this
[ __ ]
irritates me in a special way you know
um
it's just like i don't need that type of
aggregate aggravation in my life man
that's true yeah
but you it's a different story you it's
a different story because
that's your platform though it's my
house yeah
you stepped into my house yeah and you
muddied up my [ __ ] floors with those
filthy ass [ __ ] shoes
he said [ __ ] your cows [ __ ] your couch
dude
oh my god dude freaking uh oh if you
guys don't know
right outside of my office you could see
the the most ridiculous fires in
california right now it's crazy right
now so if you guys
don't know california on both uh north
and south is
burning i don't know why what happened
in uh northern california
but my mom says it's terrible like in
sacramento dude did you see the pictures
from san francisco the sound it's just
apparently orange
it looks like hell it looks like aaron
hell bro
it's crazy it looks like a [ __ ] movie
do you know what happened over there
i don't i mean i just think it's the
because the dry season
you know it's so dry everything's
catching on fire right now
well this was record record-breaking
yeah yeah in our area too i don't know
exactly where it was but it was near
azusa or it was towards the mountainside
but some fantastic beautiful couple
uh they're apparently pregnant right the
woman is pregnant so
they did a gender reveal party and they
decided to use [ __ ] pyrotechnics
and explode some [ __ ] on the day that it
was
the hottest day in la's history yeah
that's the san bernardino county
so that they started those fires but
let's speak about that [ __ ]
now not just them doing that which is
stupid as [ __ ] hell
but about these gender reveals it's been
the hottest [ __ ] thing lately dude
like
i don't [ __ ] all right do you do you
have any gripes with it about how
people make gender reveal such and like
extravagant
like it's a i don't know i literally
don't [ __ ] care same [ __ ] it's
like why
do you need to set this [ __ ] [ __ ] up
like okay
we have to make it like this and then
we're gonna do this and then we're gonna
shoot it like this and
it's like dude this podcast is brought
to you by skillshare my friends do you
know what skillshare is if you don't let
me tell you skillshare
is an online learning community with
thousands of inspiring classes for
creative and curious
people explore new skills deepen
existing passions and get lost in
creativity
now when you hear this i know you're
thinking shut the hell up i don't want
to go back into school we're not talking
about that
you know after school when you want to
work on these different projects or for
me anyways
like when i wanted to get into video
editing i didn't have any sources for me
to learn from
except for you know a few videos here
and there on youtube well guess what
we can get into specifics i am actually
learning stuff right now on skillshare
specifically when it comes to filming
the course that i'm taking right now is
filmmaking from home
turned found footage into a compelling
video
when i was starting to do videography or
when i got into filmmaking i
wish i had stuff like this that i could
reference from instead of hunting
through
thousands of random online courses that
honestly was really hard to filter
through and
i wasted a lot of time so if you do want
to learn stuff or you have a skill that
you want to dive into whether it's for a
business or whether it's videography
writing a book or anything else
skillshare is going to be there
for you so explore your creativity and
get two free months of premium
membership at skillshare.com
brain that's two whole months of
unlimited access to thousands of classes
for free get started and join today by
heading to skillshare.com
brain that's two free months of
unlimited access to thousands of classes
at skillshare.com
just [ __ ] say whether or not it's
amazing
who gives a [ __ ] and i gotta show up in
some themed costume you're like well the
theme
is that's what i'm saying the theme is
elves and lilies yeah
[ __ ] you how about that shut the [ __ ] up
right i don't give a [ __ ]
jesus yes man it's been the hottest
[ __ ] thing where they have the blue
powder or the pink powder
yeah man a boxer will always do it with
gloves it'll explode
you know yeah they'll they'll always
find creative ways to do it but i'm just
i don't i mean if i were to think about
it i think
it's become a thing maybe in about the
past five or six years
i would say i don't know when it started
becoming a thing
and the only thing i can associate it to
is the graham culture
is that you have to make this a little
bit right
it's not real but it's like dude who
gives a [ __ ]
man it's just it's the gender of your
[ __ ] child i understand it's it's
it's a big deal
right but you don't have to [ __ ]
force people to participate
in in in this uh this festivity that
you've created
to reveal the gender of your just
[ __ ] say
i'm having a boy i'm having a girl
congratulations
it's weird man i've it definitely it's
it's for the gram
and i i always crack up because i want
to see the gender reveal party
where they have i don't know let's say
two balloons right and they're both
white and you don't know what's
what it's gonna be yeah and the dad
comes up and he pops a balloon yeah
and it's pink yeah and the dude just
looks pissed
i want to see the video or the gender
reveal party where he finds out the
gender and he just gets
[ __ ] mad that he found out that it
wasn't a boy i think they've done like
kind of parodies of those type of things
of gender
i think i've seen a couple where yeah uh
either the
guy or the girl just kind of flips their
[ __ ] because they wanted you know
a certain gender but i haven't seen a
real one of that i don't give a [ __ ]
what the gender of my kid is
honestly yeah look i ideally would like
a boy and a girl just to get experience
at the same time
yeah well it can happen it's a dick come
out of a [ __ ]
that's a little bit different from what
i was saying i'm thinking twins in
heaven
about that child is a boy and a girl and
the penis comes out the [ __ ] like a
[ __ ] alien mouth
it's just a giant [ __ ] at that point
it's just the elongated clitoris it's
crazy these fires but
by the way it when you're in like for
example like the san bernardino county
they let you know that brush fires are
very
imminent like during this season it's
not something that these [ __ ]
didn't know
and if they didn't [ __ ] know they're
the dumbest people
i have never met the [ __ ] dumbest oh
who invite first of all you [ __ ] who
invites somebody to a party
on a day that's nearly 120 degrees you
are the worst host ever
if anybody invited me to a wedding a
party that's when it's 120 degrees and
it's outside
[ __ ] you and your children it's like
listen uh
i'm happy for you but i know i would
much
rather enjoy just staying indoors i know
rather than participating well i don't
know maybe maybe they just did
i don't really know the details of that
story i just saw i just
kept seeing it in the headlines of you
know agenda reveal causes these fires
now i don't know if it was that they
actually invited people to come over
and it was this party or they were just
a hundred percent it was
nobody does a gender reveal party by
themselves bro or it could have just
been streaming you know what i mean
they are not streaming [ __ ] dude is san
bernardino county
barely have internet out there they
don't know what the [ __ ] they're doing
no masks
they invited a bunch of their [ __ ]
loser friends and they
lit the whole world on by the way bring
fireworks
i know you should name your kid climate
change
you [ __ ] everything up it's terrible
yeah and and uh
right right outside of dave's place
right here you know it's
there's [ __ ] mountains on fire it's
like the craziest [ __ ] i wish i brought
my dslr
because you can it looks like a scene
out of lord of the rings
yeah yeah the fight of mordor yeah the
whole mountain side is
literally in flames yeah i'm not making
an exaggeration this is not hyperbolic
i'm saying
it's actually in flames the whole
mountain side is red right like when you
see national geographics and they kind
of have that
that long telescope lens on a camera and
you see lava coming out
that's what it looks like it looks like
an erupted volcano and the crazy [ __ ] is
it's
actually in the shape of a triangle yeah
so it's like outlining
kind of these mountains it's like i was
driving over here
and then i was like why are those
[ __ ] lights over there in the hills
i'm like holy [ __ ] that [ __ ] is fire
i almost caused an accident because i
was like
kind of uh in a trance looking at that
thing you know
yeah um but yeah it's uh it's pretty bad
that
2020 is all [ __ ] up it's 20 20 is
literally the worst so let's let's
name it off so chadwick bozeman dies
nobody knew that he had cancer
which was the saddest thing i know bro
you know what you know why i know
that number one i'm a terrible person
right but i'm also a comic at the same
time but i do have a heart
so when chadwick boseman passed away
right we were in this podcast
all solemn super sad right just because
if you if you
watch every chadwick boseman interview
he's just like a super
dope nice guy but there was a guy that
kind of tweet that tweeted out this
this um he was basically saying that you
don't know what somebody's going through
so you should be very careful about what
you say about these people when you make
these jokes because you don't know about
people's personal struggles so he says
don't he's like don't act like we forget
that you guys were calling a chat with
bozeman a crack panther
during that time now that's not even the
part that made me laugh i was like
first of all crack panther that's
terrible
right but somebody found his old tweet
and he called him crack panther he was
like the source
like he's the one i was like how [ __ ]
dare you dude
some some so somebody wrote they like
this you and they screenshotted it and
he was making fun of chadwick boseman
about his weight loss making [ __ ]
twitter jokes about him after he just
blew up on a tweet about being careful
about what you say about what people
like panther is the term you coin
it was [ __ ] hilarious dude i mean
maybe that's just his way of repenting
you know
that's just people people don't ever
believe in the [ __ ] that they say
they just they're just trying to be
famous or popular off of anything
that's why twitter sometimes is the best
and it's the worst twitter's the best
because it's super hilarious
and you can see porn on there and then
then on top of that
people will say the most ridiculous
things and the most exaggerated things
just to get a tweet and a like
yeah it's either something super social
just to see that it's about some kind of
social outrage
or they're trying to make some clearly
obvious observation
just to get people to be like yo i agree
it always comes from a
point of like entitlement that's kind of
their stance that they take
whatever the subject is but yeah the
crack panther i mean
dude when you watch his interviews he
was super thin he was i actually hadn't
seen any of those interviews so i didn't
know that he was
uh losing weight so here's the thing i
did see those
when he had lost that weight and when
people were no no
it's like low crack fat there um when i
saw that
i just thought he was it was for a role
i just assumed he was for a role you
know i was i was like damn this guy
lost a lot of [ __ ] weight but he's
probably getting into a role where it
required him to lose this much
that was it i didn't really think much
of it and then come to find out right
after his pat after he passed that yeah
he was dealing with cancer
and i was just like holy [ __ ] man that
made me think
you know it is true you don't know what
these people are going through
and you don't know who these people are
as human beings right because unless you
have that personal relationship
but you can get enough information from
kind of like what's happened and and
like what you see going on
to get an idea of what this person was
what they stood for
and the fact that he was able to keep
that [ __ ]
the fact that even his marvel family
didn't know about it that it was under
wraps that tightly
it's like man he got he gots real ones
around him
you know number one i'm surprised nobody
ratted him out
in his family that means they got tight
lips that's what i'm saying
it's like the kawaii crew you know kawhi
leonard when he was choosing what team
he was going to go
it was basically like if it leaks out i
know it's from my circle
yeah you know because i ain't talking to
nobody the only people who know about it
are like
the three four people around him and
then so if any news breaks out about
where he's going then he knows exactly
who stabbed him in the back
yeah and maybe it was kind of on that
tip too you know it's just like
yo these are this is fam right here like
people who are
who have this information and if they
leak it out
to you know paparazzi or whatever news
media
then i know exactly yeah i know exactly
who did it that just
that that shows you man when you have
people that real around you
that's kind of a testament to your
character too oh you're a [ __ ] real
one too
they do that out of respect for you as
well you know what i really appreciated
about chadwick boseman well number one
um i posted this clip that she made me
tear up was when
he was talking about how he was visiting
other termini
terminally ill cancer patients saw that
and they were children
yeah and this is why he knew that he had
that he was terminally ill like he was
going to pass away from cancer
but he didn't tell these kids that he
was going to pass away but he took his
spare time
to to make sure that these kids had what
they needed before they passed away
yeah blows my [ __ ] mind i mean says
everything you need to know about that
guy
i wouldn't do that in his time of
darkness and weakness he's choosing to
be a source of strength for other people
that's [ __ ] nuts to me that is i
definitely wouldn't do that
a hundred percent [ __ ] these because
he's dying
because he's so rich i'd be in barbados
getting my dick sucked
he's he's definitely he's definitely
somebody else
during the he knows that he has a few
months left maybe a few years
which by the way if people don't know he
was shooting films
while he was dying he shot black panther
while he was that's
nuts he was in that shape while he was
dealing with chemotherapy yeah
insane yeah i know that if if the moment
i'm shooting black panther right let's
say we're in the middle of the film
right let's say it's the asian virgin
[ __ ] uh yellow cheetah
so yellow cheetah and
during this time they're shooting and
it's like halfway through the film they
go hey
i know you you have terminally ill
cancer i'm calling off the whole shoot
i'm going to hawaii
i'm chilling on my last days but he made
sure that in his time that he was going
to make an impact
which made me actually number one it
made me kick into gear helped me
reflect a little bit so in the past ever
since that happened i've been trying to
figure out what i want to do because i
haven't really created anything outside
of this podcast yeah well now that this
podcast is set
i'm trying to think of okay what else
can i do i can't shoot any sketches
obviously there's no crews there's no i
don't want to be around other yeah right
now right
because i'm trying to do my part but it
really it really started to give me a
perspective about what i'm doing with my
time even though i'm not terminally ill
i'm not doing
a quarter of what he's doing which is
[ __ ] insane
oh no go ahead no this one oh yeah i
mean that
kind of speaks to the legacy he leaves
behind right
um leaving an example for people still
here
by the way he lived by the way he acted
and it's inspirational
and that's a huge huge testament to the
legacy he leaves behind yeah um
and it's like again i didn't know him
personally
but you get enough information about the
dude to know
like this [ __ ] was a real
[ __ ] you know he was a genuine
mother
okay i don't want to keep saying
[ __ ] he was a genuine dude you
know
he was a genuine guy and um
it's he didn't want sympathy from
anybody either he didn't tell
any publications about his cancer at all
dog he would he did
the exact opposite of what i would have
done which is
which only makes me realize i'm dying
yeah somebody help me please
i would have told everybody i was like
you know i'm dying from cancer right
don't say [ __ ] to me yeah i mean it's
just so crazy to think about because
when that happened i thought about it
from a standpoint of
what if a close friend of mine um was
going through that
and he or she ended up passing and and i
had not known about that
the whole time right and then i think
some of the um people who
were involved with them in like a
professional capacity and
a personal capacity were saying how
on a selfish level on a selfish level it
did
kind of anger them because they wish
they knew how much time they had left
with chadwick boseman
so that they could have engaged more
yeah but the fact that they'll never be
able to get that time again
there's that sense of this podcast is
brought to you by
molecule my friends are you waking up
every day
smelling crap and dust well that's
because you do not have a
molecule purifier my friends a
scientific
breakthrough in air purification
molecules core technology
pico or photoelectrochemical oxidation
actually destroys harmful pollutants in
the air
like viruses bacteria mold and chemicals
instead of just collecting them
on filters it's different breathe better
live better do you want to live in crap
ask yourself that
are you living in poopy that's you right
now it's tested it's vetted it's proven
remember
molecules pico technology and filtration
systems have been tested and verified by
third party that means we're not getting
any bs baby
you're getting the real deal breathe for
the first time in your life and cry like
i
am right now because i'm so happy
so for my genius brain listeners for 10
off your first
air purify or order visit molecule.com
that's m
o l e k u l e dot com
and at checkout enter brain remember for
10 off your first air purifier order
visit
molecule.com m-o-l-e-k-u-l-e
dot and at checkout enter brain
breathe better today kind of longing and
regret a bit
um and it's that's that part
really tripped me out dude is like to
not even know
your time with somebody is going to be
limited when they know it
when they know okay my time frame is
looking like
at best maybe x amount of years at worst
maybe a few months oh i let all of you
know i'm like i'm sorry you guys gonna
treat
i me nice gotta treat me now i'd make
you carry me out this podcast room
and buckle me into my car
a hundred percent dude say hey you guys
you guys gotta
you guys gotta not ever say anything bad
about yeah i don't want to hear [ __ ]
positivity i want you guys to post to me
every [ __ ] day
i don't give a [ __ ] this is this is my
memo account you guys gotta
i need i need money guys i gotta live a
rich and lavish lifestyle before i
know so after that what kobe passes away
this year which by the way it's
it's kobe started this whole whole
[ __ ] shenanigans of 2020 bro that
dude knew
something that dude knew something
he knew something i mean [ __ ] man i i
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna sit here and
say well
if you're gonna die at any point you
know this was the year to do it because
god knows there's millions of people
around the world who still wish kobe was
alive including myself you know
but that was kind of the beginning of it
because
up until that point there wasn't really
too much going on in 2020
and then that [ __ ] blindsided us like a
[ __ ] it was like
kobe was the last piece that was keeping
the whole world together no man
he was the [ __ ] clue to the to the
world man today they should have took
meta world peace instead man
i'll [ __ ] carry that you can't take a
guy like metal world his name is meta
world peace
he was so violent he was such a violent
basketball player but you know he
he had his he had his demons that he was
battling with and and
thankfully he took the proper me i mean
you know the story about how he came
onto the lakers right
no you don't know about it so um i think
it was
after uh boston had knocked out kobe or
knocked out the lakers yeah right
and you know the the rivalry between
boston and la is crazy
and so obviously kobe was pretty steemed
up and he was
he was uh really pissed off and he was
just brooding by himself in the shower
in the locker rooms
and a ron r test happened to be at that
game meta world peace for those of you
who don't know
um and then he just
this is a kobe this is story kobe has
told he said he just walked in there
while he was naked and showery is it
kobe let me help you
i can help you
you tell me [ __ ]
his urgency was that great he was like
let me help you i can help you win a
championship who's our test with at the
time
um [ __ ] weirdo he's weird though
i forget who he was with at that point
um
but yeah anyway that that's how when he
was butt naked and showering
let me help you well yeah i can do it i
can help you come on
you know [ __ ] yeah that that was the
story and
apparently that's what kind of uh set
the wheels in motion of
getting that's hilarious man but that's
just the kind of guy he is he's
he's so genuine you know what he kind of
has like this
childlike quality about him where he's
dumb
i don't know about dumb but he's just
pure man there's something about him
that's pure
you know your rage pure happiness pure
everything period okay yeah it's
it's almost unadulterated even though
he's been
i mean come on man when you hear about
the stories this guy tells growing up
i think he's from queens he he talked
about he saw
a friend or somebody get stabbed by a
stool egg
like somebody broke off a piece of a
stool egg
and stabbed him with it you know what i
mean so
he's seen some crazy [ __ ] growing up and
uh
those og hood stories are [ __ ] nuts
man
they're nuts when i tell my stories it
sounds so
childish compared to stuff like like
novice
who breaks off a leg of a chair and
stabbed somebody to death
that's [ __ ] nuts i know dwyane wade
has like crazy stories about him because
he grew up
i think like the south side of chicago
oh really but it's it's pretty bad but i
i
i mean i don't recollect exactly any
specific stories but he was just talking
about
yeah when i was younger and i would walk
to school i would just see people
like dead in dumpsters like legs hanging
out because somebody just got murdered
the night before
yeah and i just would be walking to
school and looking at that stuff yeah
you know times
times are so i think when you look at
the the history
of of everything it's just in the span
of 100 years
and people say this is the worst time
it's like i don't think it is i think if
you look
at things in general and just to have a
positive outlook i think these are the
best times
right because we if we could just make
point for point comparisons
yeah it's a lot better than it was 100
years ago for sure i mean
look there's obviously been a lot
of progress in a hundred years right in
technology
in terms of like uh social justice
racial justice i mean it's still things
that people are fighting for right now
but we can definitively definitively say
there's progress
now how much progress that's debatable
yeah but nevertheless progress um
speaking of that actually it reminds me
of uh
something i saw pretty recently you hear
about this lady jessica krug
who the [ __ ] is that so she's a
professor
at the uh university of washington i
believe
um so she's uh
i think like teaches african um
history or something like that um
and she's basically uh a black lady
black lady oh don't tell me this is a
rachel dolezal again yeah you [ __ ]
lie to me right now
she canceled herself she outed herself
she came and said yeah i'm just a jewish
woman
from kansas who's been claiming
get the [ __ ] identity for the past 20
[ __ ]
nobody came out and said hey you know
she looked black though
i mean she was trying to make herself
look more black that's for sure that's
[ __ ] nuts
yeah a jewish white lady from kansas is
she a professor too
like african studies or some [ __ ] like
that get the [ __ ] out here this is not
real dude
her and rachel dolezal need to meet up
just like what goes through the mind of
these people
where you make that conscious decision
of
you know what starting from today i'm
going to be blacker i'm going to be
puerto rican
funniest things that she ever said which
i didn't know was a thing she said i'm
trans-racial
no this lady said the same [ __ ] [ __ ]
the [ __ ] is with the
truth no this this this this lady said
the same [ __ ]
she identified as trans black [ __ ]
she's like dude you can't make up
[ __ ] more
he goes i was born in this filthy white
skin
my whole life but i knew
i was gonna be kissed by the golden
black sun yeah
but um yeah i think the most hilarious
[ __ ] about this is that she cancels
[ __ ] i'm trans racial too then ho
the [ __ ] that's the craziest thing you
could be trans whatever then whatever
you want to be you know
i feel like she just if you look at some
of the rachel dolezal interviews
i forgot there was a reporter that was
calling around or just even asking the
question it's like
it was something along the lines of like
i heard that you are not black this is
true
and she goes what do you mean
she just starts freezing up if you look
at a photo of rachel dolezal in the past
she looks like puritan white right right
like her father had white curly locks
and he was on that
he was a quaker on the quaker oats box
that's how [ __ ] white like if she
wanted butter she would have to turn it
herself in the morning from the cow's
pit
that's how white she is yeah i i don't i
wonder what happened
i don't know man i that that's the thing
that blows my mind too because
i obviously can't relate because i never
had a moment in my life where i was like
i'm gonna be something else i'm gonna
choose to be something that i'm not
you know trans racial dude trans-racial
trans black and and yeah she's she's
identified herself as
having like black heritage or like even
puerto ricans
i did 23 and me and she found herself to
be point
zero eight percent black doc 23 of me
wasn't around that that's oh my god this
is
this is a mental yeah this is a mental
disorder you know
that's [ __ ] nuts to me yeah and the
fact that you're able to
live that life for that long and and and
to to keep up with that lie
to the point where she almost i think
she probably almost believed it
you know there was a documentary on her
where they kind of followed her everyday
life
i think the people i think the sad thing
about it is and the reason why i don't
really clown on her too much now
is because her children are being
affected so her kids are half black half
white but they know them as oh you're
rachel dolezal's kid right
so you know they're getting bullied and
they're getting picked on and they're
getting upset about it because people
are saying negative things about their
moms
yeah but you know other part of me is
like
suck it up kid that's what your mom did
you know she got to pay the piper that's
that's a choice that she made yeah she
chose to be
she chose to be transracial
yeah i mean look the kids are obviously
paying for the sins of their mother
um but she had to have been
aware on some level that that is a real
possibility i'm trans fat
that's what i had dude i was i was
adopted into this
fat korean body i'm actually a skinny
person i'm trans fat
no you're trans skinny then no okay
that's a double entendre right there
there's two meanings to that trans fat
and trans fat
i'm trans skinny i'm supposed to be
skinny but i'm stuck in this fat ass
lumpy body
yeah if that's the case then just throw
[ __ ] logic and reasoning out the door
you could be whatever the [ __ ] you say
you are
you know i wonder if people i wonder if
she's using the whole trans-racial thing
um and bringing in uh transsexuality as
her defense
because i wonder what people are going
to feel about that people of like the
transgender community they're like hold
on
you're you're you're a little crazy
right
i mean look it's it's that's a that's a
really
complicated issue you know i just want
to see
jubilee projects should do that
transgender
versus trans-racial people doc that
would just be rachel dolezal and what's
her name
uh jessica cruz jessica krug and rachel
dolezal
just be those two because there's nobody
else in the world like that they should
sit down and have a conversation with
each other
a trans is trans-racial versus
transgender
because one's definitively real
well i mean yeah that but that's the
thing is just that
if this is like real in their mind
because
look i don't i don't know what's going
through their head i don't know if they
truly believe at some point
that they are what they think they are
um
or in the back of their head they're
always just kind of like well
i know i'm not that but this is what i
want to be
and because i'm i'm i'm just curious
because i'm thinking about what the
arguments are
right because when you read online and
you you know people who are
people who don't believe that uh
transgenderism is real
that it's it's i think people like ben
shapiro talk about it they say that it's
a mental disease that needs to be dealt
with that way
once again people don't [ __ ] crucify
me i'm just saying what other people are
saying well
i mean that's that's a stance of a lot
of conservative
uh republican christians right is that
things like homosexuality it's a mental
disease yeah it's a mental disease that
can be fixed or cured
right so if the argument for
transgenderism
right if if if they're saying that this
is the body that i
wasn't born in i guess technically
somebody could say this is also the race
that i wasn't really born in as well
so why can't i change it where's my
support group
i guess technically they could use that
argument mm-hmm and then what
what would you say to that that's the
thing right what would you say to that
but people were concerned about this
because they were saying that um
they were using the slippery like a
slippery slope type of argument that if
you do this
that it's going to lead to this and lead
to this and lead to that
right and there was a on a jk news
article a while back there was
um there was people that were
petitioning
to it was people who were sexual
offenders
like specifically against like children
they're like well we shouldn't be in
jail
because we have a mental disorder oh man
and
and you know people were saying that's a
slippery slope because you could say
that with just about anything
yeah um and and look i'm not i'm not uh
advocating um you know child abuse or
you know
any type of thing like that but we
talked about it on the podcast before
in some cultures um an age that we
would consider minors here in america is
of legal age to get married
and to have to have sexual relations so
from a cultural lens in a cultural
context right that could lend to that
argument
of hey that's just how it is in some
other parts of the world
right but it's like well yeah you can
say that
but at the end of the day here in
america the law is not that
yeah the law says you got to be 18 or
over you know
to be classified as an adult uh to
have i guess sexual relations with
somebody who's older than 18 as well
yeah um but yeah it is a very slippery
slope once you start kind of bringing in
those arguments into the picture
is like well where do you draw the line
then yeah where where
where is that line in the sand where you
can say okay well
that is where we're going to have to say
that it stops there
right now this is this is that is the
weirdest thing i've ever heard in my
life
jessica krug krug yeah krug i don't know
if it's krug or krug i'm pretty sure
it's krug
jessica krug it's so funny that for
number one she's the trans racial lady
that
cancels herself that's the funniest
[ __ ] headline i've ever heard in my
life
yeah i think a lot of people just god or
a lot of news outside
we're uh putting it like that is like um
the trans-racial canceler
yeah she sounds like canceling the
dumbest villain i've ever heard in my
life
in a comic book the trans racial cancer
when i was reading into it
this podcast is brought to you by better
help is there something interfering with
your happiness or maybe you realize that
your mental health
just needs a boost or it's something you
haven't really focused on in your life
see this year especially since we've
been cooped up with limited social
interactions we really need to check in
on our mental health i will always say
this but just to say it again your
mental well-being is as important as
your physical well-being
for those who don't know better help is
great because they can match you with
your own professional license therapist
you can schedule your sessions via phone
communicate a message online do video
calls
and you can even change your counselors
if needed if you're at home and you want
to try online counseling give this a try
please i love it and you can too
if you want to give this a try genius
brain listeners i got the hookup to get
10 off your first month of better help
just type in betterhelp.com genius to
get that offer today once again that's b
e t t e r h e l p
dot com slash genius it sounded like
there were faculty members who were
starting to dig into her past
and so she was starting to feel pressure
and that's why she outed herself before
anybody else can
um i wonder why why were they digging
into her past
there must have been something that
raised some red flags they probably saw
her cooking and she didn't use salt and
they're like hold on a second
hold the [ __ ] on a second are you black
oh my god dude she's like trying to do
too much so she just eats watermelon
every day like the most racist [ __ ] ever
this lady's [ __ ] ridiculous yeah so
that's so ridiculous
you know that was a that was a nice
little change of pace from all the other
[ __ ] that's going on
that's hilarious yeah man um and then
another headline i don't know if you've
been uh
i'm sorry i just can't i just pictured
this lady just walking in the class
she was just like what's up y'all like
what y'all doing
why are you talking like that who are
you it's like this is how black folks
speak
like no no we we speak like normal
people
like you take stereotypes and then you
take she's just next to the next level
um no but this other uh kind of headline
news that's been making the rounds is uh
i don't know if you heard about it about
trump having known
how devastating and serious the covet 19
is
from the very beginning yeah so um
recordings have leaked uh in interviews
that he did with a reporter back in i
think like february
and um he is pretty much saying
that yeah this is a lot deadlier than
the flu you know
um yeah this is uh this is pretty
serious
but i don't want to cause a panic so
that's why he's choosing to talk about
it the way he has talked about it
but it's like [ __ ] there's
almost 200 000 people dead
cause of panic yeah you could have saved
[ __ ] 200
well not all of their lives but probably
a good chunk of it
if you just said from right at the
beginning all right guys
it's some real [ __ ] this is serious we
got to take the measures to make sure
that we stay protected
dude there's been a lot of weird
misinformation too uh not too long ago
everybody was retweeting this one thing
i'm talking about
everybody who doesn't want to believe
covet is real right
that they find it to be a hoax so the
cdc put something out where they're
saying that something along the lines of
six percent of people um
who died of covid uh it was only about
six percent of the reported cases of
people who died of cobit or something
like that right
and everybody was retweeting and when i
read that i was like oh what the [ __ ]
and so
i was like if that's the case that sucks
because they said it was a lot more
so they were reporting that whatever 180
000
um people who died of cove didn't
actually dive it was only six percent of
that number
and i'm like what that's [ __ ]
ridiculous so i read the article and i
was like wait that's not what the
article is saying
so people were misconstruing it so the
cdc had to come back or people who were
reading it and
clarify it clarifies like no you dumb
[ __ ] that's not what we're saying yeah
we're saying that six percent of people
who died just died directly from
copenhagen yeah but there was a lot
you're but we're not talking about the
comorbid comorbidity
because with the other 180 000 people
the leading factor of their death
was coveted but it was they it
aggravated their existing conditions for
example diabetes they were overweight
they had asthma
this is what we're talking about we're
not talking about people who got into a
car accident and they said it was
they died from covet we're talking up
about people
we're talking about the co-morbidity and
the fatality that coveted caused that
they would have been fined
perfectly fine without if kobe wasn't in
their system
and so it's stupid that they had to
clarify that [ __ ] because people were
running a muck with that article
i mean but that's kind of the sign of
the times right where
it's just headlines you know um and
sensationalism that they people take
and then they spread that or
i guess spread a misinformation rather
than
real information just to clarify
something too i truly a hundred percent
wish covet isn't real
i i'm i'm you know what i'm saying he
doesn't who doesn't
and i'm not hyper paranoid either i'm
not walking around
just hazmat suited up i'm not wearing
gloves and stuff like that but i'm
but i'm gonna wear a mask i'm gonna do
my part and i'm going to be around other
other adults who are young and healthy
if you're old
if you're sickly and [ __ ] i'm never
going to be around you even if i feel
good just because i don't feel right
about it
also too just to just just to just to
point this out
i do have a disagreement with how our
government has been handling this
because now it's been
not even just our government it's just
people in this country right because
there is an issue with somebody saying
well you guys said that it wasn't going
to last this long
but it's now it's september but the
other side of that deal was you were
supposed to follow the rules yeah
there's a caveat to that you know
it's not just oh it's gonna go away
in uh x amount of time it's like there's
there are different variables to that
happening
you know because when people speak about
it they're they're at
they're acting as if they followed the
rules to the t
and they didn't get the said result or
what was promised to them
we as a country did not do a really
really good job okay let's
let's let's be more specific here um
not not as a not a country as a whole
yeah groups of people
yeah there's a lot of groups of people
around the country
who have not done their part yeah
actually so much so did the exact
opposite
uh because they're they are adamantly
against either the the idea that covet
exists
or the need to do take certain
precautionary measures in order to
protect themselves and others
yeah because for them it becomes
a political issue it's it's a political
statement
when you put on a mask or you don't put
on a mask yeah and you remember i was
telling you
like the the stupidest [ __ ] about this
whole covet situation
is how it became a politicized matter
yeah this is not a [ __ ] political
issue
this is a health issue you know and
you cannot look at what's going on well
actually you know what i take that back
because i am certain there are parts
uh throughout the country in certain
states and cities
where it's like nothing has ever changed
if people are just going about their
lives completely normally
and not doing any of this [ __ ] the mask
socially distancing
and you wonder why the [ __ ] we're in the
state that we're in
it's not a mystery man yeah it really
it's like
well of course we're in the situation
that we're in
and it pisses you know me off and i'm
sure a lot of other people who are
trying to do their part
to to kind of make this go away
faster sooner than later is that [ __ ]
man
because of people like that because
people like that exist
this [ __ ] just gets prolonged for
everybody yeah
and it's like dude i wanna [ __ ] have
some sense of normalcy again
you know i wanna i wanna return i really
do believe though at the end of the day
um our sense of normalcy is gonna come
back sooner than later
just because now that peop it's kind of
just known
that people just don't give a [ __ ] we're
just gonna have to deal with the
consequences now
so it is what it is just because
it's what it's now september and
businesses haven't been open for damn
near six months
people have lost their livelihoods dude
in korea town it's nuts
dude uh beverly sundu was gone beverly
was close by the 20th of this month
people will never have beverly sunday
before no man ever again
and the reason why i say this is super
sad and we i had a conversation with a
buddy of mine named matt and he's a chef
and he kind of brought this up he goes
you know it sucks that you know
a lot of the restaurants that we enjoy
specifically in very like niche areas
like koreatown um i don't think
we've kind of realized that these are
foods that we probably our kids will
never have
because these younger kids aren't number
one taking over these businesses and
they're the ones with the recipes
they're the ones that's gonna keep this
tradition up
but now like covet is exacerbating the
situation they're making it happen a lot
faster
like so if you guys don't know um
this the sundubu place which is the
spicy soft uh tofu korean soup thing
right yeah
uh it's the best spot in k-town
everybody knows this spot
um and there's also a chain called bcd
and that's like the spot that you go to
when it's super late at night yeah 24
hours
yeah right so but everybody goes to this
joint here because it tastes a lot
better and they have like this thing
called torso
pop which is this hot stone um kind of
like make it yourself
rice and vegetables vegetable chili
paste exactly yeah so
that these are foods that people won't
have and this is like an older
generation who
who probably they probably want to
retire and they're probably just doing
it out of joy but
um now because of covenant and how long
it's going they're
they're losing money so what's the whole
point it's yeah it's crazy like
how quickly things have changed and
shifted
um during the past several months yeah i
mean
it's it's just it just goes to show you
like how
fragile everything is you know what i
mean the restaurant business
i'm finding out that um majority of the
public don't they don't actually
understand
um how these numbers work so for example
there was a friend of mine who i was
telling
one of my favorite spots is struggling a
little bit and they started a gofundme
for their restaurant
and he was saying i don't understand how
they can start a gofundme when they
charge so much for their food they're
definitely taking a lot of money
in my mind i'm laughing i'm like the the
cost of their food isn't based on
perception is based on the cost of what
of the ingredients and they go well and
when you break it down people are trying
to break it down to something as simple
as well when i go home if i buy bread
this and that
you i do the math here and there it's
probably only costing about two dollars
a piece to make this so why are you
charging 14 bucks so you're not talking
about rent right you're not talking
about employees workers there's so much
things that go along you're not talking
about
um cleaning supplies you're not talking
about to-go containers
yeah water bill electricity utility
this is not that simple exactly and so
when it comes to restaurants
restaurants on average take away profit
wise 10 to 15 percent
it's that small so when you see a
restaurant and then you look at the
build you see this this place is packed
out
and you go oh if i calculated in my head
they're probably making like close to i
don't know
uh ten thousand dollars a day well
they're what they're pocketing
is only about ten percent of that right
that's a thousand dollars right that's
1500 bucks 10 to 15
and then when your your business
uh for a period gets shut down and then
once you're allowed to reopen only in a
limited capacity
think about that you still got the same
amount of 1 000 a week i mean
yeah a week a day i'm sorry that's a lot
of money right
they're balling out their money they're
making like 10 grand a week i'm sorry i
apologize
yeah i mean because look land is not
cheap in la
you know to rent out these bills
expensive yeah
it's like that kid who uh it reminds me
of kids who when they first start off
and they think that they don't need
their parents help and they go oh all i
have to do
is um pay for rent and that's it it's
like no dummy
no no that's not what it is or when they
buy their first car they go i bought my
car and i make
800 a month this car cost 700 i still
have 100
left did you forget about gas did you
forget about insurance did you forget
about
accidents yeah when you have to replace
your tires yeah oil changes
maintenance cleaning did you forget
about all this [ __ ] yeah and they
they find out that they're in a deficit
well that's kind of how it is with a lot
of these businesses when you don't own a
business you don't know what it takes to
run it yeah for sure and
look um it's hard to fault the everyday
person to
that doesn't know or understand about
these things but
it's just like don't jump to conclusions
you know yeah especially when you see a
business that's struggling and suffering
and the first thing that you think about
is well you're taking my money to make
this food yeah like how little
how do you have no empathy at all yeah
because i it's
it's safer to assume right now that
most businesses are struggling um at
best
they're just staying afloat you know and
they're just waiting for the pandemic to
end yeah
um i mean obviously there are some
businesses who have grown
um places like amazon walmart right
because they offer essentials a lot of
the [ __ ] that people still do need
are being purchased through those
portals but
most small midsize and even large
companies i mean
they've taken a major hit during these
crazy times man
and um i i think if people are thinking
oh that people
these these companies or restaurants or
whatever are trying to take advantage of
them
during this that's definitely not the
case they're just trying to make a
living trying to make ends meet like you
guys are you know
yeah it's just an example of that too
um recently so you know joe budden has a
podcast right he's really popular so joe
budden if you guys
out there don't know on the spotify
platform i mean there has been a lot of
people
uh doing podcasts on spotify there's a
few bigger names out there
yeah um but joe button is really who
kind of put
spotify podcast on the map i didn't know
that spotify
could do podcasts until i heard of joe
budden stuff which i think is true for a
lot of people i mean i'm you know i'm
just making a general uh
assumption here damn joe's joe budden
now joe rogers joe rogan
taking everything right so joe budden
recently he's not he's he's leaving
spotify
100 so i guess what happened here was
that um
they had a very specific deal that he
wanted a certain amount of money
they couldn't come to terms with it and
then joe budden felt really disrespected
but online people are saying like oh joe
budden is over evaluating himself
he doesn't know you know who does he
think he is that he can ask for x amount
of money
but in my mind just because i know first
of all whatever joe button does
on on a space outside of music now it's
gold
right he's built a name for himself and
on top of that he put spotify podcast on
the map
and i think for him he felt that um
spotify just kind of used him
as leverage to get other podcasts and
they never developed a personal
relationship with respect to what he's
done for the platform
and so the money that he asked for
apparently was
i think it was like 200 million which is
100 million more than what joe rogan
was was asking because of the leg work
that he did
into building up podcasts building the
podcast or whatever but they couldn't
come to a deal but people have been
flaming joe budden for that [ __ ]
which is kind of odd to me i don't know
why and that's what i'm saying like
people don't understand
the the back end of things yeah right
they just see oh is joe
button as big as joe rogan why does joe
budden feel like he deserves more
it's like because joe rogan didn't build
up spotify yeah i'm not saying that joe
joe budden was a part of the
infrastructure and this is just to give
a an alternative take on it
and um i don't know how joe budden feels
about it but if joe button feels like he
was a huge benefactor into getting this
platform
larger why can't he ask for some more
200 mills a lot of money
i know 200 actually i got to look up how
joe wrote
let's see let's see what joe budden said
about that [ __ ] come true
100 mill is yeah i mean i don't know how
close they got to that figure
or or if like a three-figure you know um
a three million dollar figure uh
deal was even on the table it's one
thing to be asking for 200
but what is spotify actually willing to
to offer right
um but i mean i could understand
like just being uh the pioneer the the
trailblazer who's who
created a path and avenue for these
other podcasters to come on
and and thrive on the platform to feel
like he's
entitled to to some equity you know or
not equity but you know just to share
the pie
um but i mean 200 mil does
sound pretty [ __ ] steep though you
know over how many years
was he asking for that [ __ ] i don't even
know i i don't know how many years uh
joe rogan signed for but it's i don't
yeah
you could sign me up for 30 years i
don't give a [ __ ] 200 million dollars
you own my soul [ __ ]
you take
oh here's a here's an article by variety
so joe budden says he's splitting from
spotify claims platform undermined and
undervalued
uh exclusive podcast oh it was
exclusively on spotify okay
so september 23rd i cannot tell you
where this podcast will be button said
but as it stands i can tell you where it
will not be and that is
spotify it was our and spotify rep said
it was our desire to keep joe budden on
spotify as joe referenced on his show we
made him a considerable offer
one that was significantly significantly
larger and many times the value of the
existing agreement
and reflected of the current market and
size of his audience unfortunately
we could not come to terms and we
respect his wishes to find a new home
for his show basically that's um
corporate talk for [ __ ] you joe buddy
uh he called it a bum ass deal
[Laughter]
see spotify never cared about this
podcast individually
button said on the podcast spotify only
cared about our contribution to the
platform
undermined and undervalued uh the ringer
for 250 million which he said was
actively
pitted against uh pitting pitting
against us
a button to cue spotify pillaging his
audience as a way to build up
its broader podcast strategy you pillage
the audience from the podcast and you've
continued to pillage each step of the
way without any regard
for the listeners he said in addition
button compared spotify's podcast
podcast business to experience in the
music business where he said artists are
typically exploited financially
he also mentioned by name spotify
executives who are no longer with the
company but were instrumental in
bringing him to the streaming platform
uh chief among them tuma basa who
carries spotify's popular rap caviar
playlist and is now an
executive at youtube music we can't
really talk about no business between us
before
i know what took place with my brother
tuma said button oh [ __ ]
uh button called the he i called the
howard stern of hip-hop by the new york
times first launched his podcast in
early 2015.
so he's been on there for seven years
yeah yeah and and look
i'm not surprised that they they did him
dirty like that or or in his view he
felt like he's been done dirty
obviously i don't know the intricacies
of kind of what went down between the
two parties
but it's pretty common it's just like
yeah we used you
for what you're good for you know shout
out to uh
maybe i i can kind of understand what
he's going through because
i felt similar similarly uh with
the first um the first company that i
signed to when i first came on youtube
the company it's full screen everybody
knows what full screen is a huge company
but i got signed to this guy named song
and this guy george strompolis
and george was originally from youtube
and he decided to open up his own ad
agency and you know he opened up
um full screen yeah well i left full
screen because i actually felt the way
same way joe button did
so when they at the time there was only
a couple of people that was signed to
full screen yeah it was
me uh and adam corolla adam corolla at
the time was the biggest podcaster in
the space
over joe rogan and everybody yeah so i
remember
uh george i had a personal relationship
with this guy we had meals together we
had dinner we used to kick it we just
hang out everything
so but when full screen started getting
bigger and the reason why i decided to
sign with full screen over companies
like maker
was because full screen was a company
that just started up and what was kind
of promised to me kind of like on the
table like look we're gonna watch out
for you
yeah we're a small company yeah you're
one of our first people that that we're
signing so we're going to look out for
you
they didn't do [ __ ] for me the moment
and i kid you and i'm not saying this is
some racial [ __ ] but the moment they had
other faces that were white
every [ __ ] white person was put on
their billboard and pushed it way above
me yeah that was kind of put out there
too
yeah but they didn't set me up with any
deals any brand deals no
nothing and this is during the time
brand news were super [ __ ] easy right
and so my last [ __ ] straw
was when um they were giving out these
uh small little short television shows
for people who were on the space and
they had a huge following at the time my
channel was
poppin right and i was like cool like
definitely full screen's gonna uh
throw some at me and my manager abe was
was prodding at them it's like yo
david's ready to go like he comes from a
stand-up background let's do this
they gave this kid this this one [ __ ]
white kid
uh he doesn't even do youtube anymore
he's he's a [ __ ] nobody now
he uh gave him a show to go to korea and
try out korean food and
to there's one white kid to go to korea
and do a food travel show on
my culture dude yeah and it was like a
hundred thousand or a [ __ ] 200 it was
like a ridiculous
month the kid had 50 000 subscribers
yeah
insane and that was my last i said [ __ ]
this company i would have said the same
yeah yeah and i was i literally got out
of a meeting
and they didn't do anything and george
too he says he's like after george sold
the company
basically he was saying that oh it's
kind of out of my hand so you know
joe i mean george is a nice guy but you
know at the end of the day
you know [ __ ] you guys like you did me
[ __ ] dirty like after you sold it you
made your money and you backed out and
you disappeared so
i understand how joe feels it's like
and by the way they signed a whole bunch
of talent using my name at the time
because
oh he's on the with us right yeah so i
signed a bunch of these youtubers and
they would use my name on their deck
when they had absolutely nobody
so i was like oh cool so they'll watch
out for me and i made a poor choice
because maker got sold at disney and
people had shares and then people
made millions of dollars off of that
[ __ ] yeah i would be [ __ ] rich right
now
george you're a nice guy but bro [ __ ]
you you you did not look out for me at
all man you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah that's
some cold ass [ __ ]
it's pretty much like again typical of
kind of entertainment executive type you
know man
when money gets in the way it doesn't
[ __ ] matter well no it's just uh we
need you till we don't need you anymore
yeah you know
and then once it's yeah all right so
yeah we got all these other acts now
um it's a cold he's a likable guy too
it's just like
i still like him because he's likeable
you know i don't think he has an evil
bone in his body
yeah but he does stuff that's very
disloyal it's like some
disloyal white folks dude they got that
disloyal born in the [ __ ] man you
could be
likable and still selfish i know
you you should have watched out for me
you could you could still have that kind
of charm that you put on people
you know what's funny um i don't know
george if i see you in person i'm
still going to be cornered with you not
me george i'm going to [ __ ] slap your
[ __ ] ass like
george if you ever leave that i don't
even know what you look like but i'm
going to look you up i'm going to fight
you
yeah he's like it's funny when i when i
first met him he was uh
he was all dressed in like hawaiian
t-shirt flip-flops and all of a sudden
he became an exec
at uh he was like this huge exec because
full screen blub he's wearing like these
italian suits and [ __ ] and i'm like dog
what the [ __ ] is this yeah i mean
[ __ ] weirdo but um nice guy
my name is giorgio now get it correct
yeah
i was like you know just do you know
he's doing his own thing and if i ever
see him in person i'm still being super
cordial with him
but i do think that he did have a habit
of looking out for himself
uh over others you know and and i think
the thing that's
coldest about that is because you guys
were such a small group
yeah you know and it's like usually when
it's like that when it's that
startup type environment it's more like
a family mentality yeah you know like
if we fail we fail together if we win we
win together yeah you know if we retire
we retire together but it's like nah
and it was just like ah it's out of my
control it's like bro you're still a
part of the board you still had power
you could have nudged somebody something
to somebody the right way but he just
didn't care
or or you know laid some stuff out when
he was still in negotiation
exactly and it's like damn you had no
idea the [ __ ] that i did for you
and uh yeah that's i think that's that
was one of those early onset things
where i i just
i was like man this business is very
interesting you know the thing is
as long as i've known you this is the
first time i actually heard about that
story
right i knew you you left full screen
with a bad taste in your mouth but i
didn't know the the details of it
yeah you know i'm it just it's
that was one of those things that really
[ __ ] irritated me i think i kind of
just let it go also just because
there's something about that guy where
i'm just like i don't know if he has
evil intent
in his bones but he has uh
scumbag habits right right right you
know so i've never really
i'm not even really bad mouthing him now
i'm just saying like that was a very
[ __ ] up situation
well you obviously feel a certain way
about it you know what i mean
it what maybe his intention like you're
saying
wasn't i'm gonna [ __ ] david over his
intention was
i want to be brave like i'm number one
yeah i want to be rich
but then he's failing to think about the
other people who helped to put him in
that position maybe
yeah um and as a result what happened
happened
right yeah because he even had a falling
out with like i i'm probably like
other people too i mean it can't be just
me because i'm on the peripheral in his
life so it's like
i i don't know man shout outs to you guy
i'm happy that you sold
uh full screen for whatever money that
you did and you made a [ __ ] ton of money
very happy for you but i wish you would
have just uh watched out for the people
that you said you're going to watch out
for
or at least watch out for the people who
helped you to create
what full screen was at that point yeah
to even put you in the position
to have an offer yeah to have somebody
interested in buying you out you know
what i mean it's like
that [ __ ] didn't just happen because of
him yeah right
i mean i'm i'm assuming this guy wasn't
wasn't on social media doing his own
thing right yeah
i i was there when that office was
literally nothing
like i'm talking about inch it was like
a small little office with a few desks
and then it grew
even bigger than it went to the culver
city lot then it got even bigger than
that
then they were working with like
univision and they were doing
so many different things and i just
watched it grow up from the ground up
yeah
and uh i'm not saying i deserve you know
a whole bunch of [ __ ] but what i
deserved was the relationship that i
curated with him personally
and it wasn't tactical either it was i
thought he was a really cool dude
and well it was kind of tactical because
i went there because
i i thought that i would be watched for
right right i mean no i mean there was
that was a business
that was a business yeah it was
important i shouldn't want to make her
well you [ __ ] up dude
[Laughter]
what can i say hey you dumped a [ __ ]
but um yeah that was your full screen
are they still around though
they're still still around they're still
trying to sign people okay yeah because
i
i don't know by the way kids if you ever
go on youtube and
mcn tries to sign you you absolutely do
not need them
mcn these are like full screens oh okay
you do not need them
they're basically gonna say that they're
gonna connect you with x amount of
people they really won't connect you to
anything else the most thing that they
can do for you
is get you tickets to vidcon but google
adsense is the same [ __ ] so the
difference between what they do and what
you'll do is that
they'll take google adsense which you'll
already have and then on top of that
they'll take a cut from your google
adsense so they're taking a bigger cut
now
mcns are [ __ ] useless i don't know
who mcn is you guys sound like scumbags
yeah so those companies now they're
completely useless they don't really set
you up with any great brand deals you
can curate that yourself as long as you
have a big following so
if you're ever blowing up on youtube and
they hit you up and they try to sign you
just to let you know
they'll probably disagree with
everything that i've said but every mcn
has hit me up to sign me and they are
[ __ ] useless i got one word for you
guys
yeah they're useless yeah you build up
your own following people will come
and they'll know who you are just have
an open email and after that you're good
you know who i got respect for though
is um the guys behind 88 rising
what they've been able to do with that i
guess agency slash record
it's like an what you all-in-one exactly
yeah and i remember when at first
uh they were first advertising it they
just kind of did it with a teaser they
put up like two teaser videos on their
channel and it was just like 88 rising
but there was completely it was
completely ambiguous as to
what this thing is is it a band is it
you know
an artist like what what is this 88
rising but they were trying to just
i guess use cool aesthetics to create
interest
and then look at what it is now man i
mean like they're really trying to do
everything right now
um they have uh the
brian emmanuel bryan emanuel they have
joji um
they have the higher brothers from
sichuan china you know
um they're the ones who coordinated kind
of that
whole uh the ichimo remixes with like uh
um asap fergie oh how do they do that
i don't really know i don't really know
how they uh pulled the strings are they
the chinese guys that like they have
dreads and [ __ ] yeah yeah they're the
ones who basically like do trap [ __ ] but
just rap in chinese i think they're
[ __ ] dweebs but
yeah i think they're [ __ ] i mean
they're hugely popular in in their area
though of course they're [ __ ] swagger
jackers dude like their shit's so
[ __ ]
i'm sorry like i i saw their [ __ ] i'm
like you guys
you want to talk about cultural
appropriation yeah that is
cultural appropriation to the [ __ ]
team right right but
but here's the thing within that within
that it's like
is it an an intention coming from a
negative place though
or i don't think cultural appropriation
is ever from a negative place i think
the
the the issue with that is they're
they're taking
like almost like the clownery of a
culture you know and they're profiting
off of it
well no i mean like when i say negative
it's like to be aware
that you're borrowing from from this
culture and then
like not acknowledging it well i don't
know when they still don't give a [ __ ]
yeah well i don't know i don't i don't
really know much about like that group
um i don't know [ __ ] either i'm just
saying stuff i'm an instigator
i just saw this [ __ ] and i was like you
guys are [ __ ] trash yeah joji though
[ __ ] dope uh
that kid brian emanuel didn't like a lot
of his stuff have been but he's grown as
an artist oh yeah
oh [ __ ] this kid's [ __ ] gay well you
took you took a
a viral sensation and turned him into an
actual artist
because everyone just thought you know
it's just one yeah one hit wonder it
went viral
that's gonna be it but not the dude has
been putting out consistently
good projects yeah i'm like oh [ __ ] this
kid's got something yeah um
and you know i just think it's dope how
they
took kind of like asian entertainment
entertainers and and gave them a
platform to be represented
because there was such misrepresentation
yeah uh are
under representation of asian artists
and
they turn it into a legitimate platform
you know
having their own [ __ ] festivals right
uh packed
sold out sold out uh they were supposed
to be a part of coachella this year too
yeah you know i mean and this is in a
span of like
what three four years bro yeah i mean
that's that's really
i'm going to be the next one i i need to
do i'm gonna start hey man they don't
have any comedians
i am going to start rapping though okay
yeah
then there's puppy breaks
i'm gonna learn how to rap tomorrow and
i'm going to message some people
hey your boy's in this house i have a
new song that's called peeping pop
well i don't know about all that it's
gonna happen to me more power to you man
to try
it's gonna [ __ ] happen to me you have
no idea i'm i'm a blow up
i'm gonna blow up wait so are you are
you currently with anybody now then or
no i've been doing my own thing now for
[ __ ] like six seven years yeah right
yeah um and then so i'm curious man like
youtube i saw recently had another
agreement with like their monetization
um i guess policy or whatever does that
change anything for you
so how monetization on youtube works and
you know people
on youtube can correct me if i'm wrong
they throw ads on your
on your videos yeah and obviously they
get a huge lump sum
you could also choose right of of like
how much ad you want to place in the
videos
yeah you could place you could put ad
placement i can put it every [ __ ]
three seconds yeah i've seen people do
that
yeah you know uh i don't care enough to
do that i don't really monetize much off
my off these videos anyways
just because i say stuff like [ __ ] yeah
damn
and [ __ ] gum yeah [ __ ] penis
so i say these type of things so i can't
really monetize that well either way
um but you know how the ad agency works
they they get these ads
and they they distribute it to whatever
videos that are out there and obviously
they have a large moving system for it
but now uh ever since uh actually the
huge catalyst to why this happened was
because of people like logan paul where
he was doing stuff like filming people
committing suicide
and so yeah [ __ ] that guy yeah i mean
he's just like another justin bieber you
know he has a bunch of yes men around
him he can't really think straight
um so after that ads were like yo whoa
at companies were like yeah i don't want
my ads on these type of videos and it
started going to the conversation and
some of these videos are terrorist
videos
and we're having our ads run on it so i
i don't want this to happen so that's
when adpocalypse happened where they
were just shutting everybody at
everybody's uh ads off yeah so at that
point if you were cursing you said
anything controversial you just weren't
going to get ad
on your stuff and my profits plummeted
like 90
yeah and so it was it was kind of weird
um
so now what these mcns are doing so when
you get um
when you're when you have your google
adsense and you are going to put up a
video and you're going to do ads
what happens now is they ask you what's
in this is there nudity is there ludity
is there is there a profanity what's in
this video yeah just to see what ads
that they're going to put on
yeah and so um then they now it's
selective about what type of ads on so
bigger ads
won't be on there maybe a few like
crappy ones here and there but
um for example my my cpm's what was like
what click per minute or whatever click
per minute yeah click permit
is the lowest i've ever seen in my life
at this point you might as well just
throw
[ __ ] in my face it's terrible like
people will get an average cpm of about
uh like three to seven three to seven on
the high part right my shit's like at
one something
it's ridiculous how low it is yeah and
it's been like that since adpocalypse
and i can't even fight it
so that's why we switched over to
podcast forms and i do other types of
revenue because at this point
i'm just creating just to create and
then also then viewership levels go hand
in hand with that exactly right so
they're not going to push your videos
out there because they're not making
money off of it yeah so you get [ __ ]
either way
yeah at the end of the day the platform
is made for people who do
like children's content um life logging
with no cursing
and um so you can't cuss at all
if you cuss in general they say like
profanity you say [ __ ] damn you might be
okay
but if you don't at all and you keep it
a family channel you don't keep it in
the end
if you keep it in a family area then
it's perfect then you'll you'll thrive
on it yeah it'll be dope
yeah and family content in general how
it works for ads it makes the most
amount of money
the two of the biggest genres that that
make the most money when it comes for
advertisement is uh female content
and also family content so no matter
what like i say i have a podcast right
and then we talk about controversial
stuff whatever it gets decent views
well you could have a female podcast
not not female podcast but a podcast
with a huge female audience
that gets a quarter of my views but
they'll make 10 times more money than i
will
because female the female audience has
more buying power it's just
statistically proven
so a lot of these ads want to throw
their money on uh female-based uh
audiences
and also family uh audiences because
parents will buy a lot of [ __ ] for their
kids
[Music]
yeah that's how it works out so i'm
neither of those
i'm very very different yeah but you
just wait till i [ __ ]
bust nuts and muriel and we have a kid
your boy is starting a family channel
it's gonna be called the so-sometimes oh
my god
that's what's gonna happen it's like the
only reason why i'm gonna have a kid is
so i could monetize
monetize the [ __ ] out of my kid but i'm
blurring the [ __ ] out of their ugly face
daddy loves you well guys
that wraps up this episode of the genius
brain podcast
what a fun episode we talked about a lot
of [ __ ] always random as usual random as
hell
uh you could find edric at ed2 on
instagram
make sure you guys check her out check
trek out check it out
[ __ ] secret society where you guys can
cop the clothing
um and we will see you all next time all
right joe peace